[Music]
[Music]
why aren't there any more children
lesser there used to be and why did you
only make one mothers need time to learn
this facility was designed to give
humanity a second chance one that began
with you daughter
[Music]
the path will not be easy
world outside is lifeless
but I made you into the woman that you
are so that we could sing this together
[Music]
mother
[Music]
so we've been affected by the contagion
outside I hope that in your head did you
know there were people out there I was
surprised as you
there's a boy here mother's not where
you think she's taking care of me my
whole life not mother I told you it was
dangerous outside I hope you see that
I'm different than her assailants
nothing feels nothing for you belong
here I've discovered something troubling
our guest has not been entirely truthful
with us daughter I know you're
frightened but you have no need to be
have I ever done you harm this woman
doesn't care about any future but her
own she's very dangerous if the Danes
funds ever gonna hurt in your heart
she's a risk we can't take can't take it
daughter your whole life I've taught you
to see the bigger picture
everything I do is to protect you
[Music]
you